So, I'm going to be talking about the MAJESTIC-3 trial, which I think is one of those, I think
we will in the future regard this as a pretty landmark study.
So I want to talk about how this has really changed, will change, and has changed my practice
already.
So I'll start with my conclusion, which is that, and this may be a little controversial,
but we should prefer TEK plus or minus daratumumab over CAR-T cells like cilta-cel and second
line of therapy based on the results of MAJESTIC-3.
So I think over the last several years of immunotherapy for myeloma, the working assumption
has been that CAR-T cells are more potent than Bispecific.
And that was really based on the separate phase 1, 2 studies of cilta-cel and various
Bispecific like teclistamab, where the cilta-cel response rates were these really
just unbelievable response rates of 97, 98%.
And then if you looked at the single-arm studies of various Bispecific like teclistamab,
the response rates were in the 60 to 70% range.
Although there were always, I think, some underappreciated caveats to that assumption.
So first, the top line overall response rate for CAR-T cell studies often doesn't include
the non-infused patients.
And the patients who don't get infused are often sicker, they're the patients who fail
manufacturing because their T cells aren't very healthy, and there was also very likely
a pre-enrollment selection.
And there was a pre-enrollment selection bias in some of those CAR-T cell studies for patients
who could wait through the manufacturing period, especially with cilta-cel, where originally
the trial didn't allow bridging therapy that patients weren't refractory to.
And so some of us are, I think now we look at maybe the differences in efficacy between
CAR-T cells and bispecifics were maybe a little bit inflated.
And so now we now have these phase 3 studies.
Where we're looking at CAR-T cells and bispecifics in a very similar line of therapy and a very
similar patient population.
And not necessarily compared against each other directly, but maybe in more apples to
apples comparison than those earlier studies might have been.
And so these are MAJESTIC-3 and CARTITUDE-4 use.
So you see CARTITUDE-4 took patients in one to three prior lines of therapy who were lenalidomide
refractory, randomized them to standard of care or cilta-cel, MAJESTIC-3 did basically
the same thing.
They had similar eligibility criteria and an identical standard of care to which these
were compared.
So these are the patient populations, just some very kind of summary statistics on them.
And I think they're overall similar, except for, I know by an hour at the end there, the
fact that CARTITUDE-4 did enroll more patients who had previously received anti-CD38 antibodies
where MAJESTIC-3 was an anti-CD38 naive population for the most part.
So these are the results.
And of course we're splitting cares between these two very effective therapies in and
of themselves.
They're kind of unprecedented results for relapsed multiple myeloma.
But you see here really dramatic differences between the treatment and control arms in
favor of cilta-cel and teclistamab.
And the point I would make is that...
I won't try to say that teclistamab is better than cilta-cel, but at the very least you have
to say it's comparable, right?
And so that initial efficacy difference that we saw from the phase one studies where it
really looked like CAR-T cells were more potent, it's hard to make that argument here.
At the very least, these are comparable.
You could make an argument that teclistamab is better, but at the very least you have
to say that these are comparable.
So we shouldn't think of CAR-T cells based on these results as inherently more potent,
especially in the early relapse setting than by specific antibodies.
A lot of these studies have shown that in the early relapse settings, these antibodies
were more potent.
A lot's been made of the fact that CAR-T4 had some DARA-refractory patients on it.
But if you look at some subgroup analysis of CAR-T4, it didn't look like the response
to cilta-cel varied very much between the DARA-tumormab-exposed and unexposed patients.
And so I don't think we can say that CAR-T4 sort of...
That you can't compare these populations because of that very, I think, relatively small difference
in DARA-tumormab exposure between the studies.
So if we have comparable efficacy...
Arguably, safety should really drive the decision on which one of these we use in second
line of therapy.
And so a cilta-cel has the appeal of being a one-and-done therapy, but of course, that's
only if you get through it without any major toxicity.
And we heard Sergio talk earlier about his practice where you have a handful of patients,
like 6% or something, right, that are dealing with serious complications.
And you know, you have this litany of individually rare, but collectively not insubstantial toxicities
that are severe and life-threatening.
And then at the very least, life-altering or at least making it kind of a chronic disease.
And so I think we've heard about the different neuropathies on CAR-T4.
Most of those are resolved, but not all of them.
The Parkinsonism is very rare, 1%, but 1% still for potentially fatal and serious toxicity
in second line of myeloma therapy.
We looked at our patients at Penn, and there's really this list of different immunologic
complications.
And in the patients who get those complications, there's a 17% non-relapse mortality in patients
driven by sepsis from immune suppression that's required to treat them.
And then second malignancies.
If you look at kind of the initial publication and follow-up publications, there is an accrual
of second malignancies that seems more substantial in the Cilta arm than in the standard of care
arm.
So again, we're splitting hairs here between very, very good and very, very effective therapies.
But if we accept that there's comparable efficacy in second line of therapy, it seems like we
should let safety judge that.
If we accept that there's comparable efficacy in second line of therapy, it seems like we
should let safety judge the decision.
And so a lot of folks are concerned about giving bispecifics before CAR-T cells, and
I think there's a lot of reason to worry about effect of bispecifics on infection risk
over time, and then the ability to get CAR-T cells in a future line of therapy.
However, we don't have to decide, I think if we start patients on following Majestic3
on Tec or TecDar.
I think we're going to learn a lot in the time that those patients are on that therapy
that's going to mitigate some of the problems that we currently think about when giving
bispecifics before CAR-T cells.
And I'll mention asphyxiation therapy, it's been mentioned earlier in the talk, or earlier
in today.
This is a trial that we've been doing at Penn, taking patients in the relapse setting.
So median four or five prior lines of therapy and stopping to Clistamab if they have a very
good partial response.
After six to nine months of therapy, and you see here that these patients have a median
progression-free survival after stopping to Clistamab of 20 months.
And this is in the really heavily relapse setting.
And those patients who are progressing early on, they're predominantly progressing with
BCMA negative disease, indicating that those patients would have progressed even if they
had continued to Clistamab.
You can imagine kind of porting that to an early relapse setting.
I think in the future, we're going to be able to shorten the course of therapy.
And if we shorten the course of therapy, and years later after stopping, patients progress,
I think they're going to be able to get CAR-T cells just fine.
I think T cells are going to be fit.
I think we're going to see less selection for targeted negative disease in that setting.
And also get some of the benefits of the one and done therapy by shortening the course
of Bispecific therapy.
So for a typical patient who starts Tecdara, according to Majestic 3, they're not going
to likely need another therapy for years.
And at that point, I think we're going to have learned a lot more.
We're going to be able to get them CAR-T cell therapy if they need it by limiting the duration
of bispecifics, and that the CAR-T cell therapy will likely be safer.
Or at the very least, if you're biting off the risk of CAR-T cell therapy, you're biting
it off in a later line of therapy where that risk is more justified.
And then of course, that's not even getting into the question of the accessibility and
simplicity of bispecifics relative to CAR-T cells.
So in conclusion, I suspect that Tec3 results will displace much of the early line CAR-T
cell therapy.
and at least in my practice, it's already done so.
Thank you.